[Music]
how do i trust my husband after
he had an affair with a minor she was
our babysitter we had a
little infant so your therapist didn't
make a report
[Music]
no
no
really
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john daloni show
talking about mental health
relationships whatever's going on in
your life
you're schooling today back to school
it's coming man if you made your back to
school education plans if you were ready
to get your lives and schedules back or
if you're like me i'm gonna miss my kids
we've had some great times this summer
um i'm gonna miss him i think
and
yeah anyway hey if you want to be on the
show we talk about anything whatever's
going on in your life however i can help
and walk alongside you give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291
it's
1-844-693-3291 and you can go to
johndaloni.com
ask ask and uh write in the
form
because it's uh
2002 fill out the form and uh then we'll
give you a buzz back we'll have you on
the show it'll be fantastic all right
let's get right to the calls let's go to
sarah in pensacola what's up sarah
hi
um thank you so much of course
thank you for calling what's up
um okay i
um
i don't know i guess i kind of hope i'm
coming in a place where i feel
stuck i guess um
in my marriage i i really don't know how
um
i don't know if i'm hey not testing him
yeah you're him hauling a little bit do
this just get off the edge of the diving
board and then just jump
okay just jump on it
okay so um how do i trust my husband
after um
he had an affair with a minor
um
and it's
i mean the girl is literally the age of
my daughter now and so
it's just kind of hard
okay walk me walk me through this
because
my first thought is he's
you don't trust him because he's in jail
so walk me through
well he's not
okay but um
okay so this happened a long time ago
this happened in 2006. um okay and the
girl was um my husband
he was on staff at a church and she was
around anyway
i get a hunch um
how old was hell was she
she would okay she was either 15 or 16
she had a birthday in there or 16 and
turned 17. so how old was he
23.
okay
we were young but
then how old is he now um
38.
okay
when did you find out about this his
birthday
uh
2018 um
he just kind of one day decided to tell
me and
so you found out about this five years
ago four and a half years ago yeah
yeah i mean i kind of had a you know a
hunch and so i when i confronted him
back then it was um
met with a lot of anger like you know
how could you think that about me and
you know your
blah blah blah anyway terrible wife for
thinking that and it kind of went on
like that were y'all hold on were y'all
married back when this happened
we were we had she was our babysitter we
had a
little infant
um but
he made her a baby
and did he was he is he on staff at some
church back then
he was yeah is he still on staff at a
church now
he actually just lost his job um about a
month ago good good
absolutely good man
um
there's so much here okay
um
golly so much here
let me yeah before i just start lobbing
grenades you tell me you asked your
question how do you trust him now
what what has happened in the last week
or two weeks or three weeks it
made this all bubble up because you've
known about this for five years and if
we're all honest with ourselves you've
known about this for
18 years you've known you knew right so
here we are what's made this like bubble
up to the surface
i don't know i'm not real good at um
letting myself
think about things and so i kind of
the more i've been letting myself think
about the more
i i guess angry and grossed out i mean i
become i guess you know with my daughter
being
on that age now too um is it his
daughter as well a lot
yes okay
um
and uh it's just sort of
i don't know
it's getting worse i guess more than
it's getting better i i mean we
counseling all the stuff and actually
our counselor kind of
because we're stuck i guess kind of
wanted said i just need to make up my
mind and you know until then there's
really nothing else he can do
did your counselor report this
because your counselor is a mandatory
reporter for child abuse and there's not
a statute of limitations that i know of
on child abuse
especially in a context where someone
still has access to minors like your
husband has had for the last 15 years as
a on staff minister
so your therapist didn't make a report
no
no
really
yeah i mean i i would recommend um with
all
of
my being
that
you either contact a friend who's an
attorney
or you
um file on this person's license because
they shouldn't be a therapist
at all
because you cannot let this stuff just
roll out
like your husband violated a child he
committed a crime right
yes yes um i mean everything
because i was talking to
my
pastor's wife and um she was just sort
of saying
because he ended up you know telling
them as well and
um that's not actually why
he lost his job they were just making
cuts but um
so they they oh they let him stay like
oh well all right just act better next
time
yeah i mean they did and this isn't the
first church he's been fired from
for
different things like sexual things like
this is the
well this is the second for that but
what are the other sexual things he's
been fired for
um the first one
uh
this is before i think of
before i had our first job um
it was
something with email sending emails to
the
um to someone in the church and they
link the emails to his computer which he
still denies all of it
but
i thought it was him
but
as you're that you know of and
there's knowing like cognitively like in
your head like facts
and then there's knowing
and you're a wife and a mother
and so you know
you know
has he cheated on you since then
i don't think so i mean what another
piece that graces me i was like not only
was he on staff but he was working with
like
youth group like for years like 10 years
i know i know hold on hold on
but he's not on the phone with me right
now you are
yeah
and
i always want to be respectful and kind
on this show
but i got a little girl sarah
and i've worked with ministers and i
worked behind closed doors with churches
and
my tolerance for this is less than zero
and there was a predator that you had a
hunch about and you said nothing for a
long long time
and so some of this rage and anger that
you have
is at him and it's appropriate
but it's also at the mirror
because now you're looking at a 16 year
old
who's in your home
and you're you're
going oh whoa
you know what i mean
yeah and it's hard to wrap your head
around the fact that your husband's a
creep
he's a criminal
and he does not display good judgment
when it comes to
sexuality and
uh stewarding the role he has whether
he's a teacher or a therapist or a
minister there is an elevated
responsibility to
to create incredible gaps
between you and sexual any sort of
sexual feelings towards somebody because
they feel them and it distorts
relationships
and i cannot wrap my head i think the
last number i read was
it's something wild the number of it's
in three figures it's like a hundred or
150 it's some wild number
the amount of time somebody
uh acts out sexually before they get
caught with minors
it's wild i mean it was it was i
couldn't believe it if my friend uh she
she's a researcher into this stuff into
sexual abuse but particularly churches i
wouldn't have believed it except that i
trust her so much
and so
to answer your original questions you
don't
there's nothing to respect here
yeah um
i'm more concerned that you knew about
this four and a half years ago and you
didn't
send him out the door that second
because you had a 12 year old at the
time i'm concerned that he's still
floating around like
help me with that because i want i want
i want to give you say the right thing
that you will look in the mirror and say
what am i doing
and i'm sorry that your church
leadership has failed you so
dramatically
they're they're disgusting and they're
an embarrassment they should not be in
church leadership and i hope that your
senior pastor what i hope he gets fired
too
hope he's gone for allowing this
to continue and continuing to continue
and i'm all about grace and redemption
i'm a that's that's a cornerstone of
this show
but dude i'm not gonna put you in a
position to hurt kids it's not
yeah
and i just don't have any quarter for
that man i just don't i've just seen i
just seen the wake of children man it
just causes so much disaster in people's
lives and families all that to say is
this
like
what what can i do to help you
to empower you to say whoa
what am i doing here
i don't know i mean because i
i mean as of yesterday you know just
kind of talking to him i'm like look i
really feel like i need a divorce like i
just can't look at you and
you know be okay like and so
um
i don't i don't really know what's the
hang up what's like right there what's
the hangout
i mean finances uh you know we have
three kids together um
and it's just sort of
i don't know how to navigate that
my twin brother offered to
pay for the attorney and everything i'm
just like but you know i don't know how
to go
past that like how to
live
i'm a teacher and so it's just sort of
you know
so
here's the here's the best way to look
at it um you're in florida right
um
i grew up in houston so you and i both
have a mutually similar experience which
is hurricanes coming through and just
wiping things out right yeah and we get
a couple of weeks notice and then it
becomes a few days notice and then it's
like oh this is really happening
and
then it becomes a shell game right you
don't know where this thing's gonna land
what's gonna hit it'll take out a
neighborhood but not the street i mean
not the houses across the street right
you just don't know okay
what you haven't come to terms with is
that a hurricane has destroyed
everything for you
and there's a
a stupor is that is a negative way to
say it there's a shock
when you'll see somebody walking on the
wreckage of a home that's burned down or
that's been it's been knocked down
by a natural disaster
and they are
like looking for something because they
got to pay a bill
like they just need to find that little
the little folder that had all their
bills because their water bill is going
to come due
and it's like i'm just getting to the
next thing and the next thing and it's
one of those that you gotta stop
and just walk out on the street and take
a big wide view your home is gone
okay
and what you're trying to do is your
husband threw a grenade in the middle of
your home
he threw it in there in the in the
middle of a young girl's life at least
one if not more
um and i cannot
remotely imagine there's just one
because he got away with it
got away with it
um
and your pastor failed you
probably
you're um one of the most you probably
heard me say this on the show one of the
most damning things about this kind of
situation is
you had a gut feeling way back in the
day
and you got gaslit out of your own
feelings you became the bad person for
even suggesting this happened
and you learned really quickly in your
young marriage to shut your mouth and
not believe your gut feelings
and now you're realizing oh no i didn't
trust myself and then there's a guilt
that comes with that shame that comes
all that and guilt and shame cycles us
down and then we don't act
and then you had to brave and rein the
courage to tell somebody and they failed
you they let you down
and so what i want you to do is to walk
out in the middle of the street and turn
and look
like it's a mess
and right now
i'd be really concerned about my three
little girls or my three kids i don't
know if you got three little girls and
they got a 16 year old i'd be concerned
about
my the safety of my kids
absolutely
um
finances is a thing
like i don't want to minimize that at
all
not even a little bit um there's some
harrowing data that suggests that when
couples get divorced the man's net worth
actually goes up and the women's goes
down
so yes this is a mess it's an absolute
mess and he'll have some financial
obligations obviously to your family
your life will change
whether you end up in an apartment and
this picture of your life that you've
had is going to be dramatically
different whether you've got to leave
florida and go move with families
somewhere across the country i don't
know what that looks like
but you're pretending that your house is
still standing and it's not
okay and i'm telling you that just
because i love you and i'm heartbroken
for you
and if i'm being 100 honest i'm really
frustrated with you because you should
have reported this a long time ago
but here we are okay here we are
yeah
um the best we can do
when
life is dealt us
insanity
and we either
were abused into staying quiet we said
the wrong things we did the wrong things
i have things in my past that i was like
man i wish i could have that do that
over i wish i could do that over wish i
had to said that i wish i had like all
those things
and then i find myself here
and the only thing i can do i cannot go
back and edit the past the only thing i
can do is write something new moving
forward
and so what i would tell you is your
community
your kids
and you
are waiting right now for what you're
going to write next
the past is what the past is
when you said yesterday i think i want a
divorce how did that feel did it feel
right did it feel scary
like how did it feel
i
mean it seems very i mean to even think
you know we've been married so long it's
just sort of
um
part of my life like and so it's well
obviously it's part of my life but
um i don't even know how
to go that route like
it does scare me um it should it should
be it's scary
and you say you've got a family member
that's offered to step up i mean when
you told your brother this what did he
say
oh he
he's never liked him um
um he said
when we when we first got together
honestly it was just sort of right after
some
junk that happened in college and i was
probably not in a good place anyway for
a relationship and
he was trying to tell me back then you
know it's just not a good
he's not a good guy hold on i want to
push
i want to stop with you what junk
happened
um
[Music]
it was
um
you know i explain it uh it was
um
to say it i guess call it rape okay um
say it say it out loud
it was i
got raped at work okay and um
hold on stop right there
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry that happened to you
and
that makes me think all the more that
you married a predator
someone who moves in
is that fair
tell me tell me if i'm wrong i i have no
problem being wrong
no i mean someone took everything from
you
and then somebody swooped in to fix it
make it all better
is that fair
yeah probably
i'm so so sorry
i got i'm i'm
heartbroken for you
and what that sounds like to me is that
your marriage has been over for a long
long time
and in a very uh trauma-oriented way
you've been going through the motions
keeping this thing up keeping this thing
up keeping this thing up and
um
as the great vanderkulk says the body
keeps the score and there comes a moment
when your body will shut you down
yeah and you're getting pretty close
right
yeah
yeah yeah
um i have a
um like just a policy just as a way of
life it's not for the show it's just me
just as a regular old dude in my
neighborhood who goes to tractor supply
and to get chicken food right like just
as a regular guy i don't tell people to
um
except in very rare situations that you
need to get out of a situation
and i'm telling you
i think you need to get out of this
situation
i don't see a scenario where this ends
well
okay
and
i'm
feel emboldened to say that because your
brother who loves you who knows you
better than probably most anybody else
said i'll put my money on the table get
out is that fair
yeah
yeah okay
i will walk alongside you you feel i'd
love for you to call me back through
this process and i know this is a really
heavy call i know and it's probably not
what you expected maybe that's what you
expected who knows
um
your healing journey is gonna have to
include it's gonna have to start with
you learning to trust you again
and you haven't trusted yourself for a
long long time
is that fair
yeah that's fair
you're way way stronger than you think
you are
and you've had a predator for years
telling you to shut up and you don't
know what you're talking about and how
oh my gosh it's so dumb
and then you had a bunch of kids and you
just got busy
and then you got fired again and you
thought what am i doing
yeah
um
if i'm you that's all i can say i can't
tell you what to do if i'm you
i would hang up this phone and i would
go for a walk
and if you're a person of faith i would
pray
if you're not a prisoner of faith
anymore
um i would
do box breathing around my block
which is just breathing in four holding
it for four exhaling for four
and
holding it for four again
and i would do that and walk around my
block
and then i would call my brother
and say i want to i want to meet
because i have to make some changes
and
whenever we go through a moment love
like where we realize everything's
different
um
having somebody a couple of people in
our lives that we trust that will walk
alongside us is paramount because we
don't make good decisions we don't think
clearly our bodies are in a state of
fight or flight and yours has been in a
fight or flight for a long long long
time
so having somebody who's clear-headed
who will walk alongside you man
someone's going to financially help out
for a season
um is beautiful and great
and he'll help you find an apartment if
that's what you have to do and he'll
help you when your husband blames you
for all this and tells your daughters
this is all your mom's fault all that
crap that's gonna happen it's all that's
coming
you said earlier you don't remember
like this has just been your life
and so let me tell you what's on the
other side of this thing
um
you haven't slept a full night's sleep
in a long time
and
you haven't felt
desired and loved in the way that uh
husband or wife
should
and you haven't felt safe in a long long
long time
that's what i hope for you
because you're worth all that
thank you so much for the call we'll
walk alongside you in any of those tell
your pastor call me love to talk to that
dude on the phone we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe cause you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to susan
in chantilly lace with a pretty what's
up susan
in virginia hi hey what's going on
well i seriously considered doing this
call entirely in song lyrics but then i
realized i'm 40 and i'm tired listen
to my questions listen
i'm in my 40s too no excuses we only do
song lyrics i'm in if you're in let's do
this well my last blip knock concert was
20 years ago that's half my lifetime ago
you're last night
your last what concert
slipknot
oh yeah it's been a long time for me too
so if we could do lori berkner and raffy
i'm in
i can't hang i couldn't hang all right
i'm i'm i'm tired and old too all right
let's let's just do it
so my seven and a half year old daughter
seems to have a super high level of
self-preservation
and i just kind of wanted to talk
through
um where that would have come from or
what we can do to to help her and
support her because it doesn't seem like
as i look out on other her peers
that
she's she seems to be a bit more than
them at this age okay what do you mean
by self-preservation
so
she
doesn't like she doesn't really
associate with peers that much
she likes older kids specifically older
girls
and
she seems to look down on peers
judgmentally yeah
and so um my husband and i do a lot to
try to
not make our kids feel like they're
wrong about like i don't want to make
her think she's like the way she is
wrong but i just i don't know how hard
to push her or
um what's developmentally appropriate
and just kind of wanted to get your
feedback it's fantastic okay seven year
old
who's yeah okay
oh i mean there's a lot of fun we could
have with this one um sure
so out of the bag and
i'm gonna throw some things up against
the wall and your job is to tell me when
i'm wrong okay okay and i have no hard
feelings so you can be like nah you're
wrong
but i'm usually not is that fair is that
cool
um
she
which one of you is like that in the
real world you or your husband or both
my brother your brother
is he with is he in the home with y'all
no
okay she sees him maybe three times a
year and that's
um
you know a day at a time or something he
doesn't you're broke she doesn't see
that so that means it's probably you
that she's getting this from
i guess
it's so great okay
so
here's a couple of like big picture
things
okay number one
coming out of covid
where kids got to spend an inordinate
amount of time with their
parents this is not uncommon
okay
kids have especially younger kids have
been introduced to
adult conversations in a way that they
haven't traditionally been exposed
and so i don't know what your work from
home situation has been like i don't
know what the schooling and the masking
and the home school i don't know what
y'all's situation is like
but the first thing is to think of
has your daughter been exposed to more
adult conversations
my six-year-old daughter has um
she
she would rather hang out with well it's
not true not totally but she's being
engaged in more adult conversations or
been around more adult conversations
than my son ever was because he was in
school with a bunch of other
like
knuckleheads
and so that's number one
the second thing is is
um
kids obs kids
you can imagine me you listen to this
show very often
okay you'll get a kick out of this
um i was in a counseling conference once
and they were talking about childhood
development and the ways to interact
with kids and then the presenter some
fancy phd psychologist turns around and
goes oh yeah we all know this but i'll
just reiterate it
uh kids under the age i think she said
seven or nine
cannot
process sarcasm
they can't process it so they hear the
words as facts
they'll even laugh with you they'll get
your jokes but their body internalizes
it as data
and i raised my hand i was like i need
to stop you right there say what and so
when i were saying things about like my
closest friends in the world like that
guy's an idiot or oh great my friend
todd's coming over
todd is one of my favorite people on the
planet
but i'm just being a goofy
my son was internalizing that as dad
doesn't want this guy to come over
and then dad got to watch me smile and
carry on and hang out with my friend and
it made my son very confused
see what i'm saying so if your
daughter's growing up in a sarcastic
silly fun
like oh my gosh household
there's an elevated understanding of how
the world works you see what i'm getting
at
i think so is that possible
are either of those situations possible
we're not
uh
super sarcastic but we are silly okay
and she does use sarcasm
so she's definitely she would have
gotten it from us but i don't
i would have to actually think about
that more okay think about that more and
by the way i should have prefaced this
whole thing with this
everything moving forward
please please please
don't hang on to a shred of guilt
okay
all we're doing is learning like new
skills okay
there's no i don't want you to hang up
and be like oh no our daughter's screwed
up because of me not at all not at all
okay your daughter's clearly got two
parents who love her a lot which is
going to get her as far as she needs to
go okay
that's really important here's another
question do you have friends
yes do you go hang out with them
sometimes yes
yeah
it's a lot of play dates and then i just
push the kids away so the moms and i can
talk
so you you go
she gets to see you having adult friends
yes and especially this last year before
that no okay
so this is like a new thing let me ask
you another question ish and you just
alluded to it which makes you want to
high five you
is she the center of the universe
meaning
when your husband you get home from work
your husband gets home from work do
y'all have adult talk time then you send
her away
yes okay
so sometimes senator of the universe i
am a part of the adult conversations not
a part of the kid conversations okay so
she definitely definitely wants to be
part of our conversation and she tries
really hard okay oh great and that that
means you are fun to be around right i
wouldn't that's not something to like
lose sleep over tell me when she's with
her friends
what what what's the concerning behavior
so
going back a little bit she was a
daycare baby for four years okay
and i
came home with my kids
and we were home for a year before covet
hit so we were kind of
in internal like figuring out how we
wanted to do things as a family and we
didn't do a lot of social things that
year we started getting involved in our
church and then covet hit and then
everything came to a complete stop and
she was four about yep she was four when
i came home and she was in daycare from
six weeks to the day until
her fourth birthday okay
and so for the first like eight months
when i was home she would cry when we
had to leave the house we have to go get
groceries i don't want you know i don't
want to go that kind of thing
um and so we just took it really easy
and relaxed she didn't want she still
doesn't want to leave the house
sometimes yeah a lot of the time
um then covet so then this last year we
homeschool we were part of a co-op and
it took her six to seven months
to warm up to anybody in co-op yeah um
she would beg you to leave as soon as it
was over
even though i was trying to talk to
people and
model that
you know try to make relationships and
my son is the social butterfly so he
wanted to stay but she just begged me to
leave
so um in the last couple months i've
been able to push her more into
play dates and
activities and she just she walks away
from kids we'll go to the playground and
she'll find to make it's too hot it's do
this it's i'm hungry i want to go i want
to go home it doesn't matter what it is
she finds a reason to not
engage even when the kids are super nice
and they ask her what she wants to play
and what does she want to do she'll go
climb a tree by herself yeah i think it
has less 20 minutes it has less to do
with the individuals and my guess is
her body's telling her she's not safe
with other people
and
um
i would probably like
so like the picture you're painting for
me is a very dialed in remarkable mom
and
dad and
also a weird glitch in the matrix which
i when i say glitch in the matrix
there's a combination of
particular bodies body i have a more i'm
more sensitive to things then my son is
more sensitive to things than my wife is
like in our response to things okay not
in a
helping you know people when they're
sick but i have a more sensitive body
my adhd is a response to a more
sensitive body everybody's got different
bodies right that respond to things and
so you take a body that's
highly attuned highly relational highly
smart
and every day for four years she misses
mom as his mom and then all of a sudden
i get mom all the time
all the time and you can imagine
don't use your thinking brain
but you can imagine a four-year-old body
that's been a little bit high alert
where's mom where's mom where's mama's
mom
just suddenly relaxes in a deep way for
the first time in a long time
and then all of a sudden it's we're
gonna disrupt this and it's like there's
a body saying hey so what we're gonna do
is we've got to over time
teach her body that is actually safe
with other people not only is it safe
that's the key to
growth and peace and all that given the
as attuned as you and your husband are
i would if this is my kid i would take
my child to a play therapist and have
them do a assessment of my kid because
i'd want to check and see if is she on
the autism spectrum does she have social
anxiety disorder
is there some
some
play therapy some ways that we can get
to some of the fears behind the actions
right
and kids speak via play another thing
you may want to try is draw pictures
with her
okay say like hey we're gonna draw
pictures of us playing with our friends
and you draw a picture of you
sitting with some moms or i don't know
if you play volleyball or tennis or
whatever you go do or you you're on the
softball team or whatever is going on
and have her draw pictures of her
playing with kids and that often art can
be a way just like play into a
conversation that otherwise if you just
ask a seven-year-old like why don't you
want to play with everybody she's like i
don't know
um but yeah when you're drawing or when
you're coloring it's another avenue and
the pictures will tell you a lot
okay but i i would if that's my kid i
would i would get with a registered play
therapist in my area and they
are magic and they're really frustrating
to watch if you watch them behind the
one-way glass because you it really
looks like you're just taking your money
and flushing it down the toilet
you're like what is actually happening
right now and it's pretty magical what
what can happen with a good play
therapist
okay i just watch her
stuff things inside stuff things inside
she won't talk she won't say
you know what's bothering her and it's
just it's all internal and she looks at
people on the playground when they're
laughing and screaming like they're
lunatics i mean
it's like
that um
if things are if she's in a room and
it's chaos she does she can't she can't
she hates it yeah so she she cleans it
up
she right she'll clean it all up
not the room i mean like noise like
sunday school at church she doesn't like
to go to sunday school because it's just
a bunch of kids
you know yeah going and playing i would
i would go have her just have a workup
done and they'll give a uh
um a perception inventory that will let
her like bright lights or loud noises or
things like that it may affect her a
little bit differently and again
she again she may be on the autism
spectrum um i don't know how she you
have to sit down and do an aba
assessment which i'm not qualified to do
but
all to say is it
often
the sounds the noises the experiences
the overwhelming stimulation in an
environment
you just slowly over time teach a kid
how to
a regulate their own bodies and b know
when to step out and see
um know how to interact in there because
we gotta we gotta get on with our lives
the one thing i would caution you on is
um
balancing her need for relationships
which is important with overwhelming
um situations
so if she is tell if her body is telling
you i can't do sunday school it's a lot
right now until you get some more firm
answers i would say cool you can come
sit with me we are going to church
we are leaving the house
but you can stay with me and staying
with me involves not talking
draw you can color on this picture
i will not have a conversation with you
this is not playtime mom is engaged in
sunday school mom is engaged in her book
club but you can sit right there you're
not going to sit on an ipad either i'm
not going to further overstimulate you
but you can um
not be in this chaos does that make
sense
oh yeah yeah that's exactly what i what
i wanted to know yeah yeah it is how
hard to
she she begs me for things to do she
wants friends i know she wants friends
and then it always turns into like i
know she's lonely yeah and that's that's
that that's that that's the scary thing
with not scary that's a dramatic word
that's a heartbreaking thing because she
knows what she's missing
but her body's telling her don't go in
there
and i just feel like i
i just i don't want her to be somebody
other than she is but i'm just i'm
scared that she's going to miss out on
the beauty and magic of
childhood and right fun and tag and
friendships and just because she's so
inside okay two two important things one
yes if she's got it just um
a social anxiety what they'll do is
they'll slowly it's um exposure therapy
they will slowly turn the dial very
they'll read books about kids playing
with friends they'll draw pictures of it
and they'll talk about it they'll
encourage you to have one friend invite
one friend over to her to your house and
let her play there right so we're going
to slowly open up the gate there right
um the second thing is this and this is
the pot talking to the kettle okay this
is just two parents
hanging out
i really struggled for the first several
years of my son's life because he's
different than me
and i had a picture of what a great life
was
and it was running around the
neighborhood with a whole bunch of kids
causing chaos and mayhem and staying up
too late and getting in trouble and
that is not my son
and i really wrestled with yeah but if
you would just do these things and he
would put his hands over here you know
what i'm saying like this is what
yeah and so
um i would also challenge you like let
her have her own planet right let it
it's gonna look different she may be a
person who just keys in on one or two
close friends and you're a social
butterfly and you like having people
everywhere
so that's letting our kids be them
themselves and letting them be all in on
themselves
it's when they can't they really want to
have friends but they can't even hang
out with one right they can't hang out
with one
um all that to say is i mean a lot of
these conversations i have with moms and
dads it's
moms and dads are chaotic and they are
not plugged into their kids and they're
blaming all their issues other kids i
don't see that here at all
not even a little bit i think your
daughter won the lottery with you and
your husband
um
in a pretty remarkable way
um i think now it's a matter of let's
get some professional opinions who can
actually watch her over a couple of
sessions and
see some behavioral patterns
and also um
just take into consideration hey we're
gonna have a friend over to our house
and we're gonna play from this time to
this time and then you can have some
quiet time on the back end i'm not going
to force your body into things when it's
telling you
otherwise
but we are going to have some boundaries
and um you're not going to run our
household right so this is that that
fine balance there but
hey let me know what the um child
psychologist says the child counselor
says i'd love to
get some feedback on that that would be
really helpful for me just personally
and i want to hear about how your
journey's going we'll be right back
all right we're back let's take one more
let's go to joe in waycross georgia
what's up joe
hey what's up john we're rocking up man
what are you doing
um just trying to get better day by day
how we're here that's exact exactly the
same
exactly the same so what's up man
um just had a question uh been listening
to you for a couple months now and um
one of the things you say all the time
started to brought up a question with me
i wanted to ask you um
uh you said all the time uh one of the
keys to being well uh owning and
acknowledging reality
yes and
as someone that struggled with mental
health issues most of my adult life
i have a hard time
being sure what reality actually is
sometimes yes sir
um
how can we be sure of that because i'm
always being told like i'll set
boundaries with people and relationships
and then when i start feeling those
boundaries are being squashed i'm always
being told
i'm wrong
who's telling you who's telling you that
joe
just you know everybody it's like you
set boundaries and
and this is you're always the problem
you're always fault
give me an example
um
well uh ex-wife that i just got divorced
from uh girlfriends uh parents
but give me an example of a boundary you
set then somebody
says you're that you're the dummy for
having a boundary
uh like well since i've been divorced
and started trying to date again you
know i'll
i'll say from the beginning whenever i
start seeing somebody these are certain
things i don't i don't want to
do
like there are certain
aspects that are expected in a
relationship you know it seems like
people only want
you for certain things
um
okay so let me put let me throw
something out there
let's say
you're dating
and you say hey i don't pay for anybody
else's food
i just paid for mine
and also i'm not interested in a sexual
relationship i just want to date and
have fun
and by the way i only watch horror
movies that's it i only watch crazy
slasher films
in and of themselves
all three of those boundaries
they're not crazy or wrong or whatever
they're yours
and somebody can opt into a relationship
with you
or
they can opt out of a relationship with
you
it's when you decide that your the
relationship the allure of being with
somebody is more important than what
your body's telling you is important
um becomes a problem or when it violates
your values right
right should any of those ring a bell
well yes because that's what i'm that's
kind of what i was getting at because
it's like people
i feel like people only want
to be around me for what i can provide
to them not for me as who i am
and whenever i call them out on that i'm
made to feel like a bad person okay
because it's like okay when i'll start
seeing somebody it's like okay i want to
spend time together get to know you but
then it's like okay
um well you know hey
since you're here you know
you know why don't you cut my grass or
why don't you
you're handy why don't you why don't you
build me these shelves or it's like hold
on you know i know somebody can come
over and do plumbing work if you want
you know because i've had many different
jobs in my life
i came to spend time with you not to be
your employee and that was my
that was how my ex made me feel okay
which is you know and
i don't want to do that again so when i
start feeling used that's one of the
one of your callers made me
realize that one of my diet previous
diagnosis might have been one of my
problems
and i'm burning bridges too fast
have you have you felt have you been
used your whole life
i feel that way yeah
but then i started questioning if i was
just burning bridges too fast because
um here's two important things okay are
three important things
number one
if you and i spent a significant amount
of time together you could probably tell
me some pretty wild stories from when
you were younger is that fair
yes okay you probably went you've
probably seen and went through a lot as
a kid is that fair
yes okay
often
those things that our bodies had to do
to keep us alive
when we were kids
like
i'm gonna do all the chores around here
so the dad won't hit me anymore
i'm gonna make sure this house is
spotless so that mom won't fly off the
handle and smash the cabinets
i'm going to maybe if i
fill in the blank if i disappear they
won't hit me or abuse me if i
get between mom and dad he'll hit me
instead of hurt like we have all of
these
behaviors that we had that show up when
we're kids in their survival
and then those exact same things our
bodies remember those relationally and
they show up and we're adults
the nerd word is maladaptive they screw
up our adult relationships because
we're not trying to survive anymore
and it all it means is our alarm system
is pretty highly attuned
and it's it's what was once keeping us
safe a uh
a
alarm that detects smoke is really
important in a kitchen or in a house
it's not very helpful over a campfire
right same alarm is detecting the same
set of chemicals and in one place it's
really important one place it's ruining
everybody's good time because we just
want to have s'mores right so here's you
asked a brilliant question joe a really
important question
and
you and i have different diagnosis
probably but i've had my own mental
health challenges my whole life okay
especially into adulthood
here's the um two important things
that um
guide me moving forward okay
number one
is i get other people particularly in my
case and in your case other men
that we do not have um other people in
our lives that are not romantic
relationships but they are
accountability and trust relationships
okay
what that looks like is this
if my wife says something or does
something over a period of a couple of
days
and i get to a point where i'm raged out
my body is acting in a bonkers way
because i know my wife loves me and i
know she wouldn't like try to hurt me
but i just get angry i have a couple of
men in my life that i'll call and i'll
walk through the situation and they'll
say dalona you're acting crazy
and
because i know that my feelings can be a
lot sometimes and my emotions can be a
lot i know that i don't always trust
them and so i've got a couple of guys
that i do trust that if they tell me hey
you go apologize to your wife until
you're sorry
i'll go do that because they're right
see what i'm saying so i have a group of
men in my life that i outsource that i
trust
the other thing in my life
is that i have a very clear sense of
what i call the objective data okay
i don't always feel like exercising i
don't always feel like saying i'm sorry
i don't always feel like writing a thank
you note i don't always feel like
going to bed
but i know those things help keep me
well
and so i know the data is more important
than how i feel most of the time
does that make sense
yes so i've got some objective data in
my life that i am pretty tied in with
okay whether that's meeting with a
doctor which i which i have or whether
that's coming up with objective you know
my heart rate variability and i know
when i need to sleep versus wanting to
go exercise and things like that
i know i need to eat healthy most of the
time because if i don't then it starts
to be on a path and then i end up being
a being bonkers down the road right um
but
all this to say is i know
that my feelings and emotions aren't
always they tell me a lot but they don't
always tell me the truth
okay and so i'm gonna find people that i
trust and i'm gonna find data that i
trust
and i'm gonna let those guide me when
i'm struggling now here's the big number
three
the goal for all of us whether we
struggle with mental health or not
is to learn to trust our bodies
okay
and if somebody asks you to do something
and it makes you feel less than or
uncomfortable or like you're being used
trust your body joe okay
enjoy
until you have a close friend that's a
mentor and you tell him and he says dude
just help out
but if you feel like you're dating
somebody and they're treating you like a
like a handyman
go with your gut on that one okay
okay is that fair
oh yeah i mean that was just a example
okay yeah no i know i know
but
um
that's how i navigate and that's how i
tell other people navigate one of the
wild things about psychiatry and mental
health challenges is
at the root of your question which is
there is no objective blood test for
depression or anxiety there's no blood
test for obsessive compulsive disorder
right
so you have to take somebody who's
struggling
with their thoughts and their feelings
and emotions and communicate them in a
way to a doctor
that they can take a very imperfect tool
with imperfect feelings and senses and
data and try to give you a perfect
diagnosis that's why i have a lot of
struggles with a lot of diagnosis that
people get
um
but yes the whole idea of it it's tough
right so
get some people that you trust get some
data that you trust in your life i feel
good when
i'm at this weight i feel good when i
exercise i feel good when i've slept
this many hours
um
oh i feel even better when i sleep this
many hours because i've got a continuous
glucose monitor now that monitors what i
eat and i've got a whoop strap or
whatever that or the honu strap that
monitors my heart rate variability right
all these things that you can
get in your life that you can
trust so some of the times i think i
just need to sleep in i sleep in i can
look at my heart rate variability like
nope i need to go run
great man because i know enough to know
about myself that i don't always trust
my feelings i always trust my emotions
so i hope that helps answer your
question joe it's a great great question
and i'm really grateful that you reached
out and asked um get some people man
and get the right numbers around you and
then
trust that body we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
thank you for being with us thank you
for continuing to walk with us um we
keep getting the show numbers and it's
just growing
like
bananas with i can't i'm just so
grateful i'm overwhelmed with the
gratitude so thank you so much for being
with us for passing this show on your
friends
uh for leaving reviews for doing all
things thank you so so much um song of
the day
dude i actually love tears for fears
they were one of my jams did you ever
get into them kelly
oh yeah very much so oh did you yeah oh
man i didn't think their hair was long
enough or teased up enough back in the
day
there's photos
[Laughter]
tears for fears man a great song called
mad world and it goes like this
all around me are familiar faces and
worn out places and worn out faces
bright and early for their daily races
going nowhere
and their tears are filling up their
glasses no expression
hide my head i want to drown my sorrow
no tomorrow and i find it kind of funny
and i kind of fin i find it kind of sad
the dreams in which i'm dying are the
best i've ever had and i find it hard to
tell you because i find it hard to take
when people run in circles
it's a very bad mad world
it is a mad world and that's why we're
here good folks we'll see you soon
[Music]